today we're talking about cyberpunk's
latest patch some weird xbox controllers
and a tiny update on cyberpunk's
expansion
back in february cd projekt red made
significant progress towards their
redemption arc with the 1.5 update of
cyberpunk 2077 an update that proved to
be a substantial overhaul for the sci-fi
shooter well now the game has received a
new update 1.52 that continues to tweak
several lingering issues while it's not
as massive as the previous update
there's a significant number of
improvements in the gameplay department
issues related to missing loot broken
animations and teleporting wrecked cars
have been fixed console-specific fixes
include addressing corrupted saves being
imported from ps5 to ps4 as well as xbox
series x and s controller disconnects no
longer resulting in a player being stuck
and wet roads should have an accurate
amount of reflection on the ps5 version
that's comparable to the pc edition of
the game okay come clean who was the
person who complained to cdpr about that
last one or was it just a reddit thread
that was like roads not wet enough or
roads too wet on ps5
reminds me of puddle gate from spiderman
ps4 other fixes include clearing bugs in
quests like automatic love and path to
glory as well as your vehicle spawning
closer to v when it's summoned you can
see a full list of the fixes in the link
below and before we move on to our next
cdpr story
sweat and snacks are gonna be all in
that fur these custom xbox controllers
are not being offered for sale
commercially but fans can enter a
sweepstakes to win them the controllers
come in sonic blue and knuckles red and
their standout feature are the coatings
meant to represent the bristly texture
of real world hedgehogs however if i
knew nothing about the sonic movie my
first thought would be that this is an
elmo controller and a cookie monster
controller but maybe that's just me let
me know in the comments if you really
want this pair of controllers and why
but alright back to cdpr news yesterday
the studio announced a new witcher game
is in development and will be built
using unreal engine 5 but it won't be
exclusive to epic game store on pc the
studio's partnership with epic also
doesn't mean it will abandon its own red
engine anytime soon cd projekt said in a
statement that the upcoming expansion
for cyberpunk 2077 will be developed
using red engine instead of unreal 5.
which totally makes sense i mean i've
never developed a game before but i
assume having your base game in one
engine and your expansion in a totally
different one will probably break the
experience completely and that's not
something you want while you're on your
redemption arc come on unfortunately
there still isn't any official details
about what the expansion will focus on
or when it will be released cyberpunk's
post-launch development roadmap was
delayed so the studio could focus on
improving the base game cd projekt red
is also developing a playstation 5 and
xbox series x and s version of the
witcher 3 wild hunt and is scheduled for
release during q2 which is april through
june and speaking of the witcher the new
director for the next game in the series
reacted to concerns about mandatory
crunch at cdpr a reported problem that
plagued the development of both
cyberpunk 2077 and the witcher 3. in
response to a tweet developer jason
slama said quote never on my watch
promising better conditions for those
higher to work on the new title since
those initial reports of crunch cd
projekt red has been putting work into
changing their workplace culture with
the 2021 strategy update saying that the
studio was working hard to minimize
stress prevent burnout and give its
employees everything they need to focus
on the work with a fully positive
mindset but okay the video is over but
like really for real do you do you
really want those fuzzy controllers why
do you want those fuzzy controllers i
know people collect controllers but like
is it just for collecting does anyone
plan on using those controllers i'm
sorry i'm gonna be thinking about this
all day i'll see you tomorrow